vous étiez près de lui vous le
connaissez bien est ce que le michel
louvain en privé privé l'a pas avec
quelqu'un du public était le même que
celui qu'on croit vraiment connaître
c'est à dire un gentilhomme un homme
droit un homme respectueux exactement
exactement le même angle le monsieur
qu'on voyait sur scène
cette bande elop qui est malade lui
cette gentillesse cette admiration qu'il
avait et ce respect qu'il avait pour le
public de la cité c'était un satin blanc
qu'on croise à et qu'on allait qui ont
parlé à la versa elle n'a pas les
spectacles c'est exactement le moment où
on était sûr s'allier à un ennui mois il
faisait partie du spectacle que je
faisais en hommage à charles aznavour
il arrivait en surprises avec une
chanson qui l'a popularisé se plaît à y
mourir pour toi que vous connaissez
sûrement qui a été écrite par jarre dose
d'amour et peu de gens ne le savaient
donc c'est un surprise que je faisais au
public et quand il avait mis sur scène
c'est à une ovation à chaque fois et lui
il s'émerveillait comme un enfant au
madame du miel de dylan il était de
l'escaut tes gars mère lui qui était
émerveillé encore toujours et le
connaissant des baux de long tout cet
amour qu'il recevait comme s'il démarre
et appelle dans son coeur il avait fait
l importance que vous êtes 6 et
émerveillement là qui faisait que les
gens le savent est totalement sincère
sur scène quand il chantait donc il y
avait une vraie connexion avec le public
complètement leur il était de louis on a
décidé pour moment ensemble
quand il agrée sur son moi je prenais
plaisir la seule ville à l'assemblée
puis le regard d un retrait parce que
michel c c'est une école cesser il a
ouvert la voie à tous les artistes qui
ont subi par lâcheté dont je fais partie
et est en jeu
registre exemple sur nous c'est un
exemple à suivre c'est un monsieur de
classe d'une des gares respecte tout le
monde
non seulement le public n'est tous les
gens avec qui on travaille que ce soit
les techniciens que ce soit des gens
construction des réels qui sont dans
l'ombre il il ne laissait jamais ce pour
conquis la ville allait toujours à tout
le monde
vous savez là mais parce qu'il savait
très bien que le succès de ce spectacle
c'était l'intervention de tout un chacun
et que tout le monde avait sa place dans
mon succès de l'entreprise conserve
était-il conscient totalement de
l'impact qu'il avait auprès du public du
fait qu'il est ainsi mais serait-il
étonné aujourd'hui de voir autant de
gens de partout dire à quel point ils
les avaient touchés
il a mon avis après tant d'années il
veut savoir l'impact qui l'avait élevé
certainement réaliser voir que depuis
toutes ces années et encore aujourd'hui
quand il partait en tournée c'est sale
et écoute toi donc imaginer que le monde
l'aimait maintenant je pense qu il avait
ce naïveté cette candeur là encore c'est
lui qui qui aurait fait qu'il aurait été
qu'ils seraient extrêmement touché et
est surpris de voir à quel point les
gens et j'en ai mais à ce point là vaut
mario pelchat vous il a été comment dire
à une inspiration il a été un mentor
comment vous découvriez votre relation
gelé surtout codée sur les plateaux de
télévision qui l'animait entre autres
choses de bonne humeur matériel et on a
pris en six bus sur dix spectacles
d'artistes ou dans le parti lui aussi
est ce que je trouvais ce que geneviève
c'est qu'il aimait après un spectacle
prendre une bonne bière n'imaginez pas
comme ça qu'il m'a donné on en avait
fait la liste argenteuil et on est à
trois rivières on en a deux
l'essentiel ce samedi-là puis entre les
deux et ils diront avoir une bonne bière
à l'hôtel on dit halal ou d'un autre
hôtel et y en aura c'est comme on aime
bien la dame demande une peine ferme à
oppède moi aussi pour y retourner faire
le spectacle
c'est un monsieur qui est de l'avis que
c'est un bon vivant jamais d'excès
cependant toujours toujours dans la
rectitude toujours douloureux la
tonalité 2 est-ce que ce style là avec
lui meurt où il ya encore mais vous vous
êtes la preuve que les chanteurs de
charme les chanteurs kiki wii qui
courtisent qui charme leur auditoire
ça existe encore mais est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une partie de cette histoire qui
viennent mourir de ce genre de chantage
probablement mais un autre que moi je
jeu j'ai appris de ces chanteurs dans
mon père l'a nombre de ses participants
et donald audrey de montigny moi j'ai
appris c'est lé chanteur qui choie chine
on est parent c'est la logique que
jamais donc j'ai essayé ça a été de mon
école et puis ose espérer que des gens
qui suivront ce modèle d'un temps parce
que c'est un modèle à l'effectif des
plis et puis il est revenu le public a
toujours été leur moi j'ai cette chance
d'avoir encore un public hélas qui suit
ça fait 40 ans cette année et je
continuerai de garder cette trajectoire
est gardée michel parent c'est un
exemple si mario d'un chat merci
beaucoup de nous avons parlé c'est très
apprécié merci au revoir